when you look at all the stones
filmography you think waste on war films
he's done political films he's done
controversial film's star biopics do you
feel like Snowden is a great marriage of
everything that he's done a hundred
percent I don't think there's another
filmmaker alive that could have made
this movie properly the way that Oliver
did this thing that the government is
doing right now goes against what my
country stands for we're lucky to have
the right to do that not everyone in the
world lives in a country where they even
have that privilege to question their
government and and I think it is
patriotic to do that and and and that's
what Oliver does in his movies and he's
he's really the only one that does why
would you say it was more difficult
perhaps in other films you've made this
is a tough movie to get made because the
situation is also alive it can change in
any moment and we don't know until the
movie comes out we feel we threaded the
needle told the story of his life before
during and after these events and we
think we dealt with it honestly because
we went spend time with him I think
we're pretty close to close to what he
went through it shows us that that
Snowden always intended to be a patriot
that was his goal he wanted to serve his
country he believed in his government
it's only in the pursuit of that
ambition to serve his country that he
was made privy to all this horrifying
information that he felt he had to do
something about the job was to support
the telling of the story of Edward
Snowden and that story was beautifully
laid out in the script by Kieran and
Oliver what did you learn from observing
someone like all of a stone he told he
knows really what he wants he's put in
so much prep before going into the movie
that you know when he gets on set he
knows exactly one so if you're not doing
it he's not afraid to tell you is it
right that he brought a hacker on to set
to show you how easily so he hacked well
I was day one I think he brought a guy
in um that just showed you how easy was
a hack into your bank account into your
computer and it was terrifying
terrifying doing this film did it make
you question technology in any way
because I kind of walked out very
paranoid I still have a computer I still
have a knife
I have band-aids over my cameras but at
the end of the day you sort of endorse
this behavior when you're disempowered
when you don't have the information but
what Snowden did for us is give us an
information and now at least we're
empowered enough to know I know they may
be recording me with this microphone but
I'm choosing this instead of it being
done behind my back without the
knowledge of choice privacy used to be a
human right and it's not a human right
anymore and that's something that we
should start talking about thank you
good as a google search except instead
of searching all in what people make
public we're also looking at everything
they don't emails chats SMS whatever you
have a rich people all kingdoms no way
you